hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer questions
from one of my readers Bridget who wrote
in saying she's not sure if she has what
it takes to be an entrepreneur and one
of my bison what to do so Bridget I
think a lot of people go through this
before they start their own business I
think the best thing you can do is start
by tapping into your passion so the
number one thing for entrepreneur
setting new business is follow something
you're passionate about do something
that gets you excited something that you
think you can add a lot of value and
help people out that's kind of number
one so the next thing is you don't
necessarily have to start your own
business own from the very beginning I
would go go work for somebody else who's
already doing what you're trying to do
so whatever your passion is look at you
know again that what excites you where
you like helping people and find
somebody who's already doing that and
offer to work for them and what I try to
do is get involved in that business as
much as possible so you're working to
learn you're still working for somebody
else but you're working with the goal of
eventually being able to become an
entrepreneur so you want to learn as
much as possible about how that business
runs try to you know take an extra hours
help the entrepreneur as much as
possible you ask any business owner
there's always too much work that
they're doing so you know when star
employees come up and say hey can I help
with something they love it right most
employees don't take that extra
initiative so you could be that person
you'll get a whole bunch of new
responsibilities often things that you
weren't hired to do but it will really
help your education because you're doing
this not necessarily for the money but
you're doing it for the education you're
doing it to learn how to run a business
in that industry you may discover that
this isn't what you thought it was that
you're not really excited about this
it's not your passion you don't really
want to open up a company in that space
and it was a great learning experience
and you did it without having to invest
a lot of money in fact you were paid to
learn about it so you know that's not
the situation go out and find another
job again in a similar industry that you
think you're really passionate
you want to learn more about that be the
easy way to kind of get started and then
the last thing I recommend is modeling
success so try to find people who've
accomplished a lot in your area of
choice and look at how they got started
and I see that usually they help for me
when I had my first real company I was
19 years old about tech software company
it was young guy didn't know what I was
doing had to go out and start selling
this software totally afraid so I just
started researching other famous
entrepreneurs with sold software I
thought you know I'm not the first guy
to go on try to sell software so our
research companies like Microsoft and
mcafee and into it and looked at how did
they get started now how do i think you
know make an extra million now but how
do they go from nothing to getting that
company off the ground and I looked at
their strategies for success and pulled
that into my business as well and that
was able to help us grow and that kind
of gave me the confidence to know that
hey these guys started from nothing just
an idea and look what they're able to
turn it into if I could do even a
quarter of that or a tenth of that I'm
still make a success so looking at those
stories and seeing how they came from
nothing just like where I was gave me
extra motivation and actually belief in
myself that I could do it so for that
helps so make sure you follow your
passion work to learn go to find you
know a job in your industry they help
you learn about the industry and then
model success to give you confidence and
ideas to be able to launch your own
business hopefully that helps if you
guys liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below and if you have a
question or we have something to add to
this video as well I love to hear from
you if you want to leave a comment under
the video and we'll see you on the next
episode
you
you